[Music]
OK. How do I increase my understanding
of AI beyond off-the-shelf packages?
I've got the answer to that one: you have to
build things. I mean many of the most capable
AI practitioners just put effort into building
things for themselves, reimplementing things.
You know, one great example of that
is the Stanford PhD grad Andrej Karpathy.
So Andrej has had a career, first working
at Tesla and now he's back at OpenAI,
but you know he's also just a weekend
hacker who likes to build things.
And the reality is that just by building
things for yourself from scratch,
even if they replicate something that someone
has done or a big framework from a tech company,
you just learn so much and that's
always a great exercise to work through.
OK, what are some promising
new career paths within AI?
So there are a lot, right. We're still at a stage
in which there's just a huge shortage of
machine learning engineers and a huge shortage of people
with a good understanding of neural networks,
natural language processing and
robotics and related technologies.
So if you get good skills in these areas
there are all sorts of things that you can do.
Every kind of industry, whether you're thinking
the car industry, people in banking and finance,
people in construction, people who would like to
automate mining or agriculture, anywhere you
look there are ways that you could use artificial
intelligence to reinvent different Industries.
OK, I've completed the basics of machine learning
and deep learning, what should I learn next?
I don't think that's a question
that has a one-size-fits-all answer.
One answer is find a project that's something that
you're really interested in. It could be somethingat work
or it could just be something that'scompletely
an interest of yours as a hobbyistthing.
So spending more time actually building an
AI application from beginning to end is still a
huge further learning exercise after doing one
or two of our classes. But there are lots of
other great classes you could do and I think
at that point it depends more on what you'reinterested in.
[Music]